this video is sponsored by surf shark
900 chapters
this is the most excited i've been in
the entire story and that
includes marine fort
[Applause]
wado is the best article i've yet read
in one piece or
at least so far it feels that way i've
only read act one but this part of the
story at least has captured a feeling
i've not felt reading one piece
since alabasta and to be honest i might
have enjoyed it even a little bit more
basically what i'm saying is so far this
arc has been some of
if not the best one-piece material i've
read and if it keeps up this tremendous
standard until it's climax
it will go down as my favorite arc in
the entire series
over 20 years deep and we are still
getting stories that are blowing me away
with how beautiful they are
and how well executed they've been but
enough of me blustering
let's get into this because it's
honestly amazing i'm totally not mark
and today i want to share with you my
first impressions of thoughts on and
review for
the stunning the shocking and the
mysterious
act one to the one r yeah
i saw the mental blade cut through flesh
and bones
there was something about wano that
captured my attention right away and
that was how it's presented and
structured typically or more commonly in
modern storytelling narratives tend to
follow what i'm sure many of you are
already aware of
the three-act structure a writing
principle or format popularized by sid
field in his 1979
book entitled screenplay in his
explanation of the structure he asserts
that act 1 covers the setup act 2 the
confrontation
and act 3 the resolution now if he were
to take the alabasta arc as an example
act 1 would be where crocodile
establishes himself and his desires
within the story as well as set up the
driving motivations for the main
characters of the tale
this would be when kroc pretended to
save the town has the meeting with the
rest of his organization and when the
straw hats start marching their way
toward yuba act 2 is always longer and
less refined being much more open to
interpretation typically it contains a
failure or obstacle not met by the
protagonist which they will have to pick
themselves up from thereafter
more recently the second act has been
split right down the middle by a
turning point within the story where
there's conflict once again
once again with alabasta this would be
where the gang get captured by croc and
thrown into his cell
this turning point can also be observed
within pretty much any arc within one
piece
in arlon park it's where usop looks to
have been killed by nami
in war 7 it's when robin looks to have
betrayed them and in whole cake island
it's when the plan for the wedding cake
doesn't go according to plan
personally i think this is a very useful
confrontation for long format
storytelling as it's great for pacing
putting the heroes on the back foot and
giving them a chance to lift themselves
up to the heights not yet reached after
this act 3 is usually the resolution
this is where our heroes now
armed with a better understanding of
their weaknesses use what they've
learned to find a resolution in alabasta
this is when luffy returns from having
lost a croc
armed with a strategy instead of going
in blind like he did in his first
attempt
interestingly however what's evident
when looking at this three-act structure
specifically when detailing long stories
is that unlike acts 1 and 3 which offer
concrete goals for the respective
sections
setup and resolution act 2 for lack of a
better term
is sort of vague and this is where the
wano arc decides to change
everything you see in classic japanese
plays
also known as kabuki plays they follow a
structure called
johaku otherwise known in the west as
the classical five act structure having
not had
any experience with the concept of joe
haku until doing research for this video
i'm pleased to see that they are
basically the same albeit having
different naming conventions for what
transpires in their respective sections
joe is act one ha has three different
distinct sections and q
is the resolution so in the interest of
time considering this video is
discussing act 1 only
or joe in japanese let's look at what
this section is supposed to achieve
instead
it is defined as a slow opening which
introduces the characters
and the story so with that direction in
mind let's take a look at what sort of
techniques and choices ah
oda has employed with constructing and
introducing us to the wild and uncharted
world
of wano taking place over the course of
16 chapters act 1 of 1
achieves a remarkable amount in a
surprisingly short period of time but
perhaps for me the most impressive
aspect comes in how accessible
lighthearted and fun it is to follow
along with for one piece to now be on
its
31st story arc and for it to be as easy
if not easier to follow than alabasta
its 11th story arc is nothing short of
remarkable and the mark of a true
visionary the likes of which i've seldom
been exposed to when it comes to
storytelling
chapter 909 right out the gate in
chapter 909 a unique tone was
established and by the time i had
finished reading this chapter i knew i
would likely be in store for not only
something different but something
very beautiful totally separate from the
events of whole cake island we catch up
with cat viper's forces and cat viper
himself
as he converses with marco of the former
whitebeard pirates apart from the main
narrative takeaway from this scene being
that he's not joined the fight and that
he has a message for cat viper to pass
on to luffy for him it also serves as a
means for us the audience to be filled
in on some small level
the activity that transpired between
marco's forces and blackbeard
right after the paramount war during the
timeskip when they sought revenge for
what they did to their captain
and father figure whitebeard highlighted
through beautifully drawn and composed
pages showing marco's emotional state
and how much he really cared for him
choosing to instead of fighting for him
any longer to protect what he held dear
the most this small village in the
corner of nowhere it's honestly
beautiful and endearing but what's more
is that despite this being the only
instance during this act where we see
cat viper and marco it was also the very
first scene of the story
oda presented us with which tells me as
a reader that this will most definitely
not be the last time we see either marco
or cat viper within this arc
with that said it's at this point the
previous scene closes and something very
different starts to happen
the panel structure is interesting
framing a curtain opening cherry
blossoms falling and shamisen playing
unveiling one of the most stunningly
beautiful revelation panels into a new
area i've yet seen presented in one
piece in fact you know what
it's the best one i think this is the
most beautiful panel in one piece so far
and what's more is that i really and
truly believe that this story's world
hasn't
looked as beautiful as this glorious
world wano boasts at almost every
available opportunity
taking this time to reintroduce us to
characters like uzop working as this
world's equivalent of a con man or snake
oil salesman frankie as a carpenter
robin
as a geisha and most importantly for now
zoro who is being reprimanded for
stealing a sword that he acquired
way way back in the story having been
instructed to keep as low profile as
they possibly could before luffy's
return
and the enactment of their plan zoro is
forced to take action to protect his
life in what i think is the
single best action panel i've seen oda
ever produce
already the story is interesting and on
a visual front i don't think one piece
has
ever looked more impressive chapter 9
10.
something i noticed while researching
for this was how closely both the story
structure
and narrative itself reflect and
complement one another the story being
that as i mentioned earlier a kabuki
play now that particular style of play
was developed during the tokugawa
shogunate a military government that
ruled from 1603 to 1868 in japan you
might have recognized the term
shogun in shogunate there and that's not
where the similarities end either this
particular government practiced
extremely strict isolationism while
encouraging native arts to flourish it
led japan down a path that eventually
had them arrive at a sobering conclusion
locked away from the rest of the world
they had become technologically
illiterate
when compared to the rest of
civilization and if this story sounds
familiar it's because
it's a clear inspiration for the wano
country in one piece isolated from the
rest of the world by the oppressive
shoguns of the time they continue to
ignore
the obvious problems that doing so
presented in this chapter luffy and the
crew arrive in the turbulent seas
surrounding wano when once again oda
takes a moment to show us some
spectacular artwork depicting towering
rock formations piercing the crushing
waves
koi fish and even bonsai trees which as
a nice artistic choice
is clearly drawn to represent the
artwork of that particular time period
in japanese history
and so with all of that implemented what
better way is there to tell this story
of isolationist japanese-style
shogunites than by structuring it like
the very kabuki place that period is
famous for developing it's a brilliant
choice that not only allows this arc to
feel distinct from the 30 others but
also feels intrinsically connected on a
personal level with the story being
explored right now
and even if i want to talk about
everything else outside the themes of
this arc
this chapter alone is both tense and
gripping with luffy and co having to use
giant koi fish to crash land onto the
country in the first place
leading oda to make another phenomenally
appropriate narrative decision
to remove every other point of view
character that isn't luffy he wakes up
on the beach
alone before being confronted by two
very intimidating creatures we've not
yet
seen in the series chapter 911
now that we have only one point of view
character to focus on the world around
us is allowed to play as much a pivotal
role in telling the story as
any other character which on top of
establishing the setup for the story and
introducing us to important key
characters
also allows us to on various levels
become more acutely aware of and
accustomed to
this brand new mysterious land going
into the story we know that wano is
closed off to the rest of the world and
so
keeping the point of view in luffy lost
and confused helped sell this mysterious
side of the world
exceptionally well while also allowing
the story to remain simple and focused
there aren't multiple plot threads here
we are given room to take in and
appreciate the world
as oda sees fit and i love it the setup
that takes place and that's in question
here
takes hold almost immediately when luffy
becomes entangled in an effort to stop
this thug from kidnapping this little
girl there's some really cool scenes
into splice like luffy using his
observation hockey to dodge and
counter-attack a sniper shot unseen and
when he uses the supreme king hockey he
subdues a giant baboon and you know
that's pretty dope now one of the main
attributes that this
act acquired when it decided to follow
the one point of view character in luffy
was its ability to endear us more
effectively to new characters like otama
the little girl he saved from that thug
she has a devil fruit ability that
enables her to take off parts of her
cheek feed it to creatures
and make them obey her she's honestly
incredibly sweet and incredibly grateful
toward luffy for what he did for her
and the little scenes here and there
that informs luffy and her relationship
are not only effective but also help
drive the story forward
unbeknownst to luffy otama has given him
as thanks for saving her
all the food she has in the world
already starving she flees to the river
to drink from it just to try to distract
her stomach from how hungry it is
it's at this moment another new
character by the name of tenguyama
hitetsu
barges in reprimanding luffy as an
intruder that ate all of otama's food
overhearing this she returns home
pleading with him to forget him before
fainting as it happens the water she
drank from the river has been polluted
heavily and now she's in grave need
of a doctor now there's nothing
spectacular or flashy about this scene
or
chapter really but it's still very
effective in establishing what it does
and endears us to otama extremely well
which thankfully gives luffy a new
immediate goal he needs to attend to
save the little girl and what's more is
that apparently
she's been waiting for a certain pirate
called ace to return
for quite a while while a small detail
this tiny piece of info further links
luffy and otama and
what's more helps bolster this feeling
that wano really is closed off to the
rest of the world
during marineford the entire world
looked on in baited breath as the most
significant battle in the history of
this series transpired
everywhere luffy went he had to disguise
himself and by association everyone knew
what happened to whitebeard and ace
but not this little girl not one-o
country
oh and additionally i'll mention this
because i just thought it was cool
oda the absolute shadowsaurus rex the
pharaoh
of foreshadowing already told us that
ace had visited wano before
way back in marine fourth through the
character of oars jr we see a flashback
where ace mentions how he learned to
make that hat
or swears in 1-0 country there goes oda
again
casually slipping in dialogue that helps
add color to a scene he won't write for
another decade
chapters 9 12 9 13 and 9 14. when the
little girl wakes up luffy informs her
that ace is dead
immediately i personally really like
this move from luffy he knows better
than
anyone that this is news not to dwell
long on rip it off like a band-aid and
move on with your life
besides then more importantly he has
another life to save right now
otama and she's fading fast with that
said after being filled in on the
circumstances that surround the island
of wano with kaido and his men seizing
all the food and fresh water
leaving the rest of the area a wasteland
and heavily polluted luffy gives himself
the job of bringing ultima to get help
but not before hitsu hooks him up with
some sweet new threads
and yeah luffy takes his sword but
notices something about it that's
familiar and it should be
well sort of this is an incredible
callback to logtown from chapter
get this 97. that's over 800 chapters
ago
back then zoro acquired kotetsu iii and
right now luffy is running around with
kitetsu too
he has in his possession a sword that's
way above his skill level and way above
the likes of anything we've seen before
or at least i think that's the case
it's one of the most famous swords in
the world and easily the longest
callback
yet in the series super impressed by
that and to be honest calling back to
prior events to either recontextualize
a particular event or to add emotional
resonance between two characters like
the way ace continues to do so between
otama and luffy these small interactions
add so much color to this world and
stand as a testament to the goliath of a
series one piece has become
luffy gets on his way and once he's
through the clearing of the trees and
after some flashbacks to ace's time
spent with otama
we finally see the wastelands of wano a
desolate eerie smoke fills the air as
factory towers
puncture the horizon this stands in
perfect contrast with the beauty we
witnessed in the introduction
we immediately have something that we
want to fix and we associate that
with kaido now and that's not even to
make mention of the gentleman luffy
happens to run into after this
[Music]
this scene where luffy and zara reunite
actually brought a tear to my eye it's
nothing flashy or special but these are
the first straw hat pirates and this is
their first time seeing each other in a
very long time
seeing zorro someone that rarely shows
that level of emotion with a massive
smile on his face as luffy jumps onto
him
is what i love most about this series
the fantastically well realized
relationships and characters there's
some classic luffy and zoro banter in
this chapter with luffy filling him in
on poisonous food situation while eating
the food himself
and so remarking that this explains why
his tummy hurts these scenes are what i
live for and that's when basil hawkins
arrives on the scene
now one thing i haven't chatted about
regarding this arc thus far has been how
ridiculously funny it is now like this
arc so far has gotten more than a few
giggles out of me throughout but
this next section where hawkins
addresses luvion zoro for the first time
i recorded my reaction immediately after
reading it check it out
i love how hawkins is like so foreboding
and zorro is like so super serious but
luffy just goes off the rails with silly
he goes like
i would advise you not to sightsee here
are you aware who controls this country
from the shadows
nope i don't know it's kind of and i'm
gonna love that emperor
[Music]
it's subtle and zoro's all like shoplife
said we're not supposed to know that
he's like
i was just kidding
i lost this chapter funnily and
interestingly enough zorro recognizes or
senses the sword luffy is using and
requests to use it but
luffy decides to fight with it sort of i
mean
he punches people while also slicing
people
by accident sort of i guess it's
surprisingly effective anyway something
i'll briefly touch on is the character
of battle hawk he seems to have been
after
siding with kaido as one of his
subordinates and he's one of the worst
generation pirates along with luffy and
trafalgar law he's based off of a tarot
card reader and his moves largely rely
on which cards he gets when he calls
upon them not exactly sure how relevant
he'll be long term but he adds a neat
little dynamic when they clash
never knowing how he will attack or
chase or even if he'll be successful
[Music]
i want to thank surfsharkvpn for
sponsoring today's video
in the ocean of online content there's a
lot of websites that take your info
without you even knowing it but you can
swim under their radar using
surfsharkvpn with this particular
service you can stop websites from
tracking your info and selling targeted
ads to you online
completely protecting your privacy
nothing is creepier than when you have a
conversation with a friend about
something and it pops up in your ads
plus with surfshark hardlock id
protection you'll even get an alert when
some rando jerk is trying to break into
your email but one of my personal
favorite features of surf shark is that
you can see content that's not available
in your area for instance did you know
that right now on netflix you can have
the first 130 episodes of one piece
well if you live in a country where
that's not available you can just log in
with surf surfshark and you can get
access to that or any other show or film
that that isn't normally available for
you
so if you want both freedom and
protection online click the link in the
description and use code tnm
it not only gives you a whopping 83 off
the regular price
but also three months of service totally
for free
surf shark also offers a 30-day
money-back guarantee so there's no risk
to even try it out for yourself
so if this service sounds interesting to
you or you want to support the channel
please
check it out now back to the video luffy
it's good to see you buddy
[Music]
looking at this story again something i
also noticed was that it was quite
efficient with its scene selection
immediately after escaping from hawkins
we're introduced to a female samurai
working in a tea shop called okiku we
learn law's forces are nearby and we
learn about some of the hierarchical
structure
in society through the wrestler yokozuna
they even have medical days that cure
illnesses and that's only within a few
pages
and i think this is largely what makes
this story feel so engaging for me
we're always learning something new
while the story remains focused and
straightforward
luffy now has first-hand experience with
how the civilizations are struggling and
therefore he sets his eyes on a goal of
liberating the country
however just as they're getting into
that another one of kaido's fake devil
fruit minions cuts in
it's batman i'm vengeance there's a
pretty sweet shot of zoro blocking an
arrow attack on the owner of the tea
shop and this gazelleman just runs off
with otama
towards the town of bakura something
that's easy to love about this chapter
is how there's never any resistance
between luffy and zorro to take the most
action-packed route to solve the problem
chopper nami or usop aren't there to be
the voices of reason and so we get
instances where the two deem it
worthwhile
to barge into a town and cause all sorts
of chaos
chapters 815 916 and 917
right about here is where the combined
forces of luffy and zorro's no subtlety
plan begins to cross a threshold of no
return
you see otama at this moment in time has
been taken because she suspected of
having a real devil fruit ability
thankfully she keeps his information
quiet despite her being tortured by
players
needless to say zora and luffy aren't so
quiet
as they begin to look around the area
and engage with all sorts of different
townsfolk i'm reminded why i love this
atmosphere oda's established whenever we
enter a new
island it has culture different
principles and dialects heck
it even has its own currency gold coins
which again just makes sense because
they don't use berries they're isolated
from the rest of the world
the same way that gold is the currency
of amazon lily and xton is the currency
of skypia
it's a small detail but it goes a long
way in demonstrating the level of
consistency
and detail one piece employs from start
to finish
now this is around the time when
yokozuna's eyes lock with okiku's and
before he knows it she's slicing off his
top knot
and he mad naturally we are still in an
expository phase within this act but you
can definitely tell we're building to
something not because luffy's going to
fight this wwf wannabe but because
you know we're backing up the chain of
command and sooner or later someone
important will bark
back and we might not like who that ends
up being luffy face palms yokozuna to
next week with some funny moments
interspliced like luffy's win-loss
record as a sumo wrestler against usopp
but in doing so blows down the living
quarters of a person called holdem one
of the main guys behind
the animal kingdom pirates around the
same level as hawkins this holdem guy's
design i can't really make heads or
tails of he's got a lion on his tummy
that
shares a nervous system and there's a
scene where he punches himself
in the balls classic however right now
he's holding otama for all the world to
see in his jaws
as a hostage now to be honest the real
threat here is less this man but more of
the appending arrival of someone we've
heard from before
jack the draught hanzo this individual
wreaked havoc on the little island but
got dealt with indirectly without
luffy's input we have no idea what will
happen if he arrives and luffy has to
contend with him
but in saying that there's a very sweet
moment that rears its head right after
the battle when luffy heats otima from
the jaws of the lion and reverses
holdem's firepower
genuinely i thought this was super cute
and it made me well up a little bit
because of just how wholesome it is
chapters 918 19 and 9 20. basically to
wrap things up
luffy and otoma dash off on the back of
this horse lady thanks to otama's devil
fruit power law fights hawkins and zoro
feeds an entire village with food that
was being held from them
alright you still there okay great
because lol wants to bring luffy to the
top of this mountain to see
odin's castle's ruins and man it melted
my brain take a look
kinemon momentosuke raizo are all the
samurai we spent the last 300 chapters
dead big question for sure and would you
believe it's actually way
way crazier than you might think it is
luffy and the gang begin ascending
towards the castle
the scenery once again looking
astoundingly beautiful i really like the
choice oda made to keep the real wano
rooted in the natural beauty of the
world and everything associated with the
forces of kaido
a wasteland getting a glimpse within
these classrooms we see that not only is
kaido poisoning the lands and ravaging
its resources but also poisoning the
minds of those young and impressionable
with propaganda
supporting his efforts interestingly
though alongside these illuminating
panels were introduced this guy called
napping kyoshiro who's recounting the
dying words of odin's wife
who died 20 years ago those words act as
a prophecy of sorts for the region
to preface this i'm still not sure where
the significance lies within this but i
have a couple of theories perhaps
all right check it out you are the moon
unaware of the dawn
may your purpose be fulfilled and cast
nine shadows on the night woven of 20
years
and you shall know the brilliance of the
dawn it's pretty obvious to me at least
that the nine shadows are referring to
the nine straw hat pirates as jinbei
technically hasn't taken his place
amongst the crew yet
and carrot is as much a straw hat right
now as vivi is but this number could
be intentionally misleading and might
refer to kinemon momo and a bunch of the
other samurai that supported this cause
additionally i'm interested in why she's
referring to them as
quote the moon obviously it works pretty
effectively for the analogy she's using
but
later in the next chapter it's revealed
that those supporting momonosuke's
efforts have tattooed a moon
onto their bodies also the verb that's
used in this
is woven now the only reference to
weaving anything in this story so far
has been this abandoned village at the
start of the act that ultima is from
where she would spend
all her days weaving hats now maybe that
location has some significance i mean
oda must have shown it to us for some
reason
there might be more to this but for now
i am reserving any further theories
because
what kinemon reveals later on is bloody
insane
this rocked my ever loving world
kinemon momonosuke and all the other
samurai that we've gathered over the
course of the last few hundred chapters
are all from 20 years in the past there
is no
time travel in one piece specifically as
kinemon recounts the events of kaido's
takeover 20 years ago describing the
events surrounding the death of lord
odin and the subsequent death of his
wife lady kuzuki toki
whom while holding her two children
momonosuke and his sister kiori
informs her loyal followers of the
following mankind cannot return to the
past
but it can leap into the future i have
used this strange time time ability to
travel further and further into the
future
until at last i arrive here at my final
destination
these quotes are ridiculously
interesting to me first of all it's
curious that she herself doesn't travel
forward in time with them it's implied
through kinemon's point of view that she
appeared to be someone that came from an
era long long ago yet despite having her
power to push people forward further
into time
she elects to stay behind and what's
more is this
she gives them momonosuke but not his
sister
that they've mentioned by name like four
panels ago personally i think this
sister
needs to play a big role in the story i
mean if she's inconsequential to the
story then they wouldn't have her as a
character in the first place
let alone a named character something
perhaps a little more minor is that she
refers to her power as
strange time time abilities instead of a
devil fruit power does she come from a
time where these powers weren't acquired
in the same way that they are now i've
got so many questions from this very
small but super interesting flashback
sequence
kinemon then goes on to describe how
they were thrust 20 years into the
future with their headstones visible and
their homeland in ruin he runs through
the series of events that led him to zou
dressrosa and eventually punk hazard
where they ultimately met in the first
place we learn that there's a sizable
following still in oneo that desires for
an uprising and thus they iron out a
plan
to raid kaido's base two weeks from now
on the night of the fire festival this
chapter
was exceptionally exposition heavy but
gave me
more than enough to think about when it
came to this world and what the
implications of it
might be now i'm exceptionally
interested in seeing how all of this
manifests later on
and now with kaido's name being thrown
around as a target and with how our
introduction to him a while back was
made i am intimidated by him but
also can't wait to see what he's made of
when luffy eventually clashes with him
down the road
chapters 921 922 and 923
alright so for those of you that haven't
seen this material before and are
currently thinking that everything up
until now in act one has been great
oh my sweet summer children y'all ain't
seen nothing yet because this next
section is the single most excited i've
been
while reading the entire story 900
chapters
this is the most excited i've been in
the entire story and that
includes marine ford
so kinemon runs through the current plan
trying to rally up the existing support
within the country to bolster the raid
makes sense and that's when we cut back
to the village all the food was given to
this thief with five a's in his name
atamayama
mole design up and boom jack is right
there looking for luffy but before they
can exchange even three sentences
this random thief it turns out he's a
samurai and an
awesome one at that slicing right
through jack with what looks like
relative ease so in my head i'm
wondering
okay so we're in act one and jack has
already been dealt with with
relative competence by a complete
unknown
yeah and then kaido shows up
and he's a massive freaking dragon i
swear mentally i was preparing myself
for jack
not kaido and certainly not super dragon
kaido the size of a town
it's an opponent with a presence size
and powers so far removed from anything
we've ever seen in the series including
big mom and whitebeard at least from a
visual level
it's also helped in large part because
at the beginning of the chapter things
were relatively calm they were
discussing things in secret and this
chapter ends with a giant kaido dragon
attacking a town what is happening
i don't know but what i do know is that
in the middle of law analyzing the
situation
luffy does say it with me now in typical
luffy fashion
runs off full speed ahead into the woods
towards kaido
the excitement i felt when reading this
was insane but seriously it only gets
better and
look i promise i'll analyze more towards
the end but god damn
this section got me so hyped it's unreal
so i got a vent
so as it happens kaido was drunk as all
hell and looking for some mighty brigand
he heard might have been the forest
at this time law catches up with luffy
during which time
hawkins catches up with kaido and in an
effort to divert his rampage away from
the village of bakuda
tells him that luffy and ko are at odin
castle ruins now what's important to
understand here is that he doesn't
actually know that they're there but
because
it's a legend that he believes will add
credibility to his claim for kaido
it just so happens that on that ruin are
in fact the straw hat pirates
and the rest of the remaining forces
hawkins is the best subordinate by the
way
so kaido just soars past luffy in the
blink of an eye before spitting fire
onto the ruins leveling the entire
area in a massive explosion luffy looks
on in utter disbelief and shock
faced with a similar reality he
experienced during the shabbat
archipelago arc
losing all of his friends in this moment
he shows a tremendous evolution of
character and strength of will as he
without delay
without crying deals an enormous
elephant gun straight to the head of
kaido and
at this moment i'm loving life so yeah
it's a pretty good chapter
crash landing onto the town below luffy
finds that something terrible has
happened to otama
at the hands of kaido as he made his way
to the village in the first place
enraged by this news luffy grits his
teeth punches the ground and screams
towards kaido
standing defiantly i'm right here kaido
in response
this asks who he is and without missing
a beat
cool as a cucumber the young man from
the east blue declares
kaido quickly unleashes a massive blast
from his mouth but by the time that
blast scorches the earth below
luffy is high in the air and begins
pummeling kaido with consecutive
colossal strikes
all over his body kaido falls to his
regular human form after this the crowd
remarks at what's happening to this god
among men
at the hands of a complete unknown luffy
engages gear 4 without delay and
unleashes everything he has successfully
meeting his mark
on the emperor of this
[Music]
the last chapter of act one after 923
chapters of emotional development
improvement and growth after mastering
his devil fruit power
upgrading it through the gears system
and after the leaps and bounds he's made
with hockey he unloaded it all on kaido
in a single chapter and with one blow
kaido knocks him out harder than any has
in the past without so much as a scratch
on him now that's an imposing villain
typically speaking this tactic for
establishing a villain or big bad by
donkey on the main characters super
early on
is a bit of a cliche but to be honest
it's not really a cliche or overdone at
all within one piece
and while this is the last chapter of
act one there's still some more
interesting and cool moments to speak of
on the cool front while luffy was
lying lifeless after the battle with
kaido and i use the word battle loosely
kaido remarks that luffy's been glaring
at him the entire time despite him
looking like he's not conscious at all
kaido walks off and that's when everyone
around luffy
falls to the ground while luffy was on
the verge of unconsciousness he
surprised kaido with his use of the
supreme king haki
i thought that was a pretty awesome
scene to be perfectly honest but in the
interest of wrapping things up the straw
hats on the hill were completely fine
because of the clutch use of a certain
female warrior's devil fruit power
frankie usop and robin hear that luffy
fought kaido and is being held prisoner
and they also make this face it's
wonderful
and when luffy's thrown into a cell he's
sharing it with
none other than kid another member of
the worst generation of pirates
what a crazy situation this should be
really interesting and with that the
curtain closes
on act 1. if i haven't made it
abundantly clear already
10 act 1 is phenomenal and easily my
favorite part of the post time skip
material it's stunningly beautiful
exceptionally well written and has a
super fun and straightforward story that
has hidden complexity
throughout for instance remember that
sword dealer way
back in low town that zoro gakitsu three
off
well during that chapter chapter 97
he said and i quote famous swordsmen
have died
tragic deaths because they wielded the
kitesu swords
this establishes the curse surrounding
the blades themselves obviously but
as we see earlier in this arc the
gentleman luffy yeets kittetsu
ii from refers to it as a cursed blade
yet again
now i'm not saying there's a correlation
between the sword and a curse
necessarily but
luffy and otama both met sinister ends
within this chapter
which is a wonderful bit of underlying
continuity i had to point out because it
was pointed out to me and i loved it
wano act one is most definitely
something i want to check out in the
anime in its
entirety after i catch up with the rest
of this series i cannot wait to see what
the rest of this amazing story will
continue to yield
as i venture into the second and third
acts in the coming weeks
if you would like to support this
channel on patreon you can do so for as
little as one dollar per video i've
uploaded all the videos in this series
that have been taken away by toei
so if you want to catch some of those
while i work out the illegal issues with
the evil japanese corporation you can do
so through the link in the description
but that'll do it for this video
as always i've been told not mark i'll
see you all next week and thank you so
much for watching